Let me guess. 47 browser tabs open,
three notetaking apps, and a 5-year plan
you revise monthly. Sound familiar?
Here's what nobody talks about. Being
smart might actually be why you're not
successful. Your intelligence has become
a prison. You can solve complex problems
in seconds. But you've been thinking
about that project for 3 years. While
you're perfecting, someone else is
profiting. After IQ 120, intelligence
only predicts 23% of success. The other
77%
has nothing to do with how smart you
are. Your overthinking brain sees every
possible failure. So, you stay stuck
analyzing instead of acting. But here's
the shift. Sometimes you need to forget
what you know and remember how to move.